bonjour et bienvenue dans cette émission
nous allons traiter aujourd'hui jean
baptiste de la française d'avant ce
bonjour stéphane bonjour à tous ou une
variante intéressante de la défense
française il y en a beaucoup
là c'est là
variante qu'on choisit quand on veut
laisser le centre fermé l'asf attention
en fait et on avance le pion pour
enfermer le faux case blanche
alors avant de voir justement ce que
c'est que cette vente précédemment on
peut citer quelques grands ports qui
jouent cette cette variante alors les
plus connus on peut on peut les citer ce
sont six ro rog reach look surtout qui
est un très bon spécialiste de la
française d'avant sachant qu'elle avait
bien employé par de très nombreux
joueurs du top mondial spécialiste avec
les blancs ça veut dire que c'est aussi
une variante pour les grands attaquants
parce que je suis refait gris choque ce
sont de grands attaquants
ce sont des joueurs qui aiment beaucoup
les initiatives c'est vrai que c'est
basé sur un contrôle fort du centre
voilà donc c'est une variante
intéressante pour ceux qui souhaitent
développer de table sur les ailes
alors on va voir ça tout de suite avec
cet échiquier et sa soeur caractérise
cette française avance par les coûts
donc que 4 aussi jean baptiste assez
caractéristique de la barrière est
français c'est la langue française oui
des cartes théâtre donc des cinq des
cinq essais l'idée de 6 on veut essayer
d'égaliser les forces au centre après un
échange
sur un échange plus qu'à te prends des
5e 6e rang des saints qui on a le même
nombre de pions au sens voilà hélas
barème d'avant ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
il ya d'autres banques françaises alors
on va passer vraiment complètement là
dessus c'est on va s'occuper dans cette
leçon uniquement de la vente d'avant ce
qu'ils vont très belles armes à
connaître des deux côtés actuellement
autant avec les blancs cabinet noir et
elle peut être très très courante
c'est une variante qui a une logique en
plus tout à fait le coup eux 5
eh bien on est en train de faire
réaliser aux noirs que on a enterré leur
fausser 8
voilà c'est un fou s'est vite ici il est
bloqué tout de suite par le pion aux 6
on a pris aussi un petit avantage des
espaces avec confiance aime bien placé
dans le camp noir ont bouchony 6,7 cette
phalange de pions voilà c'est
l'inconvénient principal quand même de
la défense française c'est la place que
va tenir le fou s'est vite dans la
partie donc eu 5
même si ça c'est d'la attention
en moi ça ne mérite d'enterrer le fou
alors il ya un petit inconvénient quand
même à secouer 5 et on va le voir avec
le couloir suivant c'est maintenant les
noirs ont leur sont renseignés sur la
forme que les blancs en donner à leurs
chaînes de pions donc ils vont attaquer
la chaîne de pion à la base
à la base tout ça là bas donc là on a
une minichaîne alors on à la base ou à
la tête et comme on veut ici on attaque
ouali cissé à la base avec des quatre
donc pour consolider le centre les
blancs jouent le coup le plus naturel
stéphane à savoir la c3 c3 si c'est
vraiment normal il faut le font pas
hésité à le faire donc là on se protège
en garde de ses enfants regardent le
sens à ces cas ci la défense française
ce sont ainsi 5 qu'on va retrouver dans
toute la défense française
voilà alors après soit on sort le kawaï
et c6 tout de suite soit les noirs qui
commence déjà à regretter d'avoir
enterré leurs fous et c'est peut-être de
le sortir alors comment est ce qu'on
peut faire pour sortir avec un moyen
assez artificiel on peut peut-être
regarder stéphane nature d'un v6 d'un v6
avec l'idée alors d'abord un jeu rajoute
de la pression sur tout à fait voilà
dame est toujours bien placé en mai si
son geste sur la case normal de la
défense françois là donc ça il faut bien
connaître et le thème des noirs que
veulent faire les noirs c'est le couffo
17 suivi de fou mais ça pourrait changer
d'ici vont lutter contre ans le club
langues
on peut pas on peut pas mais c'est pas
très grave pour les blancs parce que ça
passe a perdu temps c'est un peu lent ça
perd du temps donc les blancs ont des
arguments
alors on va cavaliers trois des sept
voiles à l'élan fou eux deux on se
développe alors on se développe quand
même c'est à dire que on n'a pas de
compte il aussi a parfois de ces
problèmes il faut jouer il faut des
coûts de développement dans nos
enseignes a pas de problème c'est prend
des quatre s'éprendre l'hécatombe est
épuré simple mais c'est vrai ça y est on
va échanger avec le noir le gouffre ou
contrôler le fond de
voilà c'est un bon il peut une
séparation peut-être un petit peu
douloureuse pour les blancs parce que ce
fou de cases blanches de la varende
avance souvent un fou d'attac
en revanche on a quand même des
compensations qui sont pas négligeables
c'est à dire sur le coup cavaliers c3
paralysante voilà on va pas prendre vis
évidemment nous mêmes non non c'est
mieux de s'en sortir encore une pièce
supplémentaire c'est ça notre
compensation c'est à dire combien de
temps voilà du temps de développement
qui va nous servir comme on va le voir
dans la suite que l'on vous propose donc
votre enfant mais je n'ai cavaliers car
allez prends parce que ce cavalier
on va le recycler en fait on en profite
en fait pour faire balader ce qu'amélie
de ce côté là on sent profiter de
l'autre côté et oui voilà on va essayer
de s attaquer aux plongées c'est théo
via f/4 5-5 chose comme ça car faut
vraiment bien connaître les blancs ce
qui se passe là parce que ce plan est
quand même plante dangereux
stratégiquement c'est enfin logiquement
est fier on a échangé la meilleure fout
des blancs voilà si on ne réagit pas de
manière rigoureuse et bien on va se
retrouver avec un influent ancien pas
terrible alors pourquoi il est pas
terrible ce fou par rapport au foot
place blanche jean baptiste et bien tout
simplement on dit qu'il est mauvais
parce qu'il est soit la couleur des
pions bloqués bon alors c'est sûr la
star qui fait doublon
c'est inception contrôler les cases
noires et se font déjà du mal à naviguer
contre le vent classe blanche étaient
complémentaires donc c'était blanche
arrivait à surfer au milieu des pions ce
qui semble être une mauvaise affaire
peuvent être transformés par le gain de
temps donc il faut se dépêcher aussi
avec les blancs contre 47 petit rock
cavaliers c6 ça c'est un plan de cuques
blanc parce que lecavalier ne sont
pouvait pas sortir ainsi selon alain
comprend et ce câble une fois en 7 il
fallait trouver une case donc les noirs
pas faire le maître en c6 la tourbe est
un donc à tomber à je protège option
alors c'est beaucoup et c'est pour
libérer le fou et je peux libérer le
fonds qui peuvent venir sur la case sur
la case d3 wire à cinq cavaliers canal à
part des blancs servat c'est là qu'on
rate déjà dans le plan voilà on commence
à envahir un petit peu les droits on a
un centre qui est stabilisé alors c'est
vrai que notre fou de cate blanchet a
disparu mais en tout cas avec cavaliers
f4 on a on commence à ramener des pièces
vraiment
manière très menaçante sur le sol elle
roi alors cavaillé 17 foudroie voilà
donc de tomber un problème de
développement complète le développement
fawcett est maintenant va laisser passer
la dame hélas hélas le coupler cette
variante cavaliers des deux cas il a
donc ça c'est le conclut qu'il faut
connaître là on enlève une défense aux
pions des quatre mais on laisse passer
la dame
c'est à dire qu'ici la menace qu'on veut
exécuter avec les lancers de venir en g
4 et 6 dames sont car voilà on va
attaquer le purger sept et en même temps
le ku'damm g4 quand même jette un oeil
sur le pion des quatre prélats mais là
on sacrifie ce pion et le problème c'est
que les normes pas trop de choix c'est
ça qui font prendre ce qu'ils ont alors
ils peuvent attendre un peu rendre le
prendre peut-être en tout cas tôt ou
tard il faudra le faire dans la partie
on a intercalé à quatre avec l'erreur ce
serait le petit rock
ouais ça serait effectivement un petit
peu dangereux quand même en imaginant le
pire tout petit rock il faut commencer à
ramener la dame comme on l'avait prévu
le mandat mme ces quatre avec la menace
simple car il est acheté un euro il ya
beaucoup de pièces d'attac mes jambes et
on peut ramener le cavalier d2 en f3
pour mac il a fait son boulot on pourra
jouer peut-être h4 si besoin
ça ça risque d'être très dangereux c'est
une bonne position pour les blancs des
antilles si on attaque
voilà donc voilà comment il faut jouer
cette variante c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on préconise enfin c'est de jouer ce
plan ne pas hésiter de le caler c3 qui
reprend le fou ici en 2010 un f4 et les
pressions sur les droits et ensuite on
va pas hésiter à jouer le plus capé 2
pour libérer la dame aussi sur le roi
donc pression très rapide
on va profiter de la danse développement
pour mettre la pression sur la
lamentable du temps pour retourner en
tout cas ce blanche
on en profite captivant vite les pièces
sur les endroits sensibles alors ça
c'est simplement c'est une option pour
lui noir c'est noir en avant ce sommet
donc on va avoir maintenant une autre
option bien sûr envie
alors après le coup ces trois donc ici
au lieu de jouer le coup d'un bbc
voilà qui était cette idée là alors où
l'on relevait plus tard mais disons
qu'on va commencer par ce coup k et ses
six cas nécessite donc là on dit adieu
pour le noir ce plan un fou 17 fou mais
simple puisque on a mis le cavalier sur
les sur le trajet
ça va pas du tout être le même le même
thème le traitement doit être différent
absolument cavalier à 3 donc je
surprotège évidemment le pion des quatre
ma demande d'amm b6 donc la dame mais si
ce qui est logique
voilà d'imbéciles c'est logique puisque
l'on met encore une pression sur le pion
des cats qui est le petit talon
d'achille des blancs dans cette histoire
est bien protégé puisque il a trois
défenseurs voilà alors qu'entre défense
la clé je dirais dans cette dans cette
ouverture soit c'est de le surprotéger
soit c'est un sacrifice soit celle de
données voila voila contre d'activité
alors on va regarder quoi d'abord le
sacrifice le sacrifice alors le
sacrifice on peut jouer effectivement le
sacrifice que les noirs ne sont pas
obligés d'accepter d'ailleurs mais dans
ces cas là le foie en d3 est très bien
placé il y est superbe c'est un très bon
fou puisqu'il org
des deux côtés il est derrière il faut
de la couleur opposée
c'est un superbe fou donc les noirs aux
intérêts dans la nouvelle pièce voilà
contrecarrer cette période ça s'appelle
comment sur une orbite c'est le gros
bill milner barry lampard milner barry
voilà un nom un peu compliqué alors ici
puis on prend des quatre qui reprend des
quatre alors tout de suite petit piège
quand même mais c'est que les normes ne
peuvent pas jouer le groupe pourtant
évident en cavale et prendrait quatre
puisqu'après cavaler prendre cavaliers
on se dit mais oui non mais les noirs
prennent on est quatre oui mais en fait
non pourquoi parce que tout simplement
fou dès cet échec une mauvaise nouvelle
mauvaise nouvelle et la dame ait perdu
puisqu'il va falloir défendre les
chèques par exemple par wade 8 et d'un
programme gagne damned
voilà le tac la découverte c'est très
pénible petit peu pénible extrêmement
violente au dire même
donc après c'est prendre des cartes il
faut d'abord jouer avec les noirs
lecouffe ou 17
voilà qui en brèche éviter la découverte
et la découverte dans ce cas là les
blancs ont pas de moyens efficaces de
protéger des cadres de toute façon
puisque le fou des trois déjà empêche la
dame de protéger s'ils ont reculé le fou
est vrai du temps ça serait vraiment pas
une bonne nouvelle aussi de il ya
cavaliers b4 voilà réseau métaux je vous
le donne et donc on le donne avec petit
rock et voilà l'idée c'est que caprica
va lui prendre cali cabaye prend dame
prend des quatre on joue le simple câble
et c3 avec la manade développement avant
tout casser
on donne le deuxième pion aux scènes qui
vont revoir qu'on va la récupérer très
vite ce pion à vous prendre cinq tours
dog [ __ ] ou aller en bibitte sinon c'est
trop dangereux de rester au centre et là
tout simplement récupère ici le pion
voilà donc quelques jours un tour de
main pour les blancs on hamm est le seul
qui ont de moins mais une belle position
parce que très dynamique très open alors
en général et noir poursuivre par le
coup mais si on a ça c'est la théorie
effectivement dame est fou attaque quand
même le volant un petit peu et sur des
matches c'est un bon jour en général
d'un match 5 qui cloue le pion à vii
à noter que le pion aux six aussi est
louée sur la tour ce qui protège
indirectement le cavalier des scènes par
exemple sur un coup qu'on fout c'est si
ce qui serait une erreur tout simplement
les blancs peuvent jouer pourquoi aussi
c'est chaud c'est possible voilà puisque
le pion ne peut pas reprendre la tour à
cause de l'échec de la dame donc c'est
pas beaucoup pousser si donc un général
et noir vont plutôt jouer le coup droit
et fuite ici et donc ceux des rocs ça
oui mais bon il était un peu trop sous
pression entre planches clouées voilà
donc ils préfèrent mettre le roi plus ou
moins à l'abri je dirais voilà le
cavalier manar est attaqué alors celle
là il faut le rapatrier on a eu peu joué
cavalier 3 on peut envisager cavaliers
ou trois ans si oui alors voilà qu'est
c3 puis je pense qu'on peut s'arrêter
pour ses variantes tout à fait hors jeu
à juste un coup d'oeil pour essayer de
l'évaluer on a sacrifié un pion voilà
donc les forces en présence et bien les
noirs ont un plan plus donc ça c'est le
côté positif
le problème c'est qu'ils ont un roi en
fuite est encore un léger retard de
développement dont c'est une partie où
chacun des deux camps va essayer de
prouver qu'il a une raison bien sûr
qu'elle vendra donc là pour les blancs
les attaquants vont aimer cette position
je vous tranquillement une belle attaque
avec un pion de moins mais au roi du
rock et les matérialistes os préféré les
noirs voilà matérialiste et les joueurs
à long terme qui aime bien jouer les
finales vont essayer de tenir jusqu'à la
finale et de remporter en gnl avec un
point de plus de tout se dire tout ce
qui arrive et après il faut y arriver
bien sûr comme dit l'autre
les finales les dieux en place et au
mieux 2 le magnifique donc à bf3 fou 17
voilà le lyonnais avait condamné six oui
pardon son ami stone 2006 donc au lieu
de donner le pion comment est ce qu'on
fait pour le surprotéger donc on veut de
jouets ou des trois ici voilà ça option
bien sûr protéger ceux qui ont des
quatre parce qu'il a un souci cependant
des quatre les noirs vont prendre des 4
et après ils vont menacer de jouer terre
et les ossètes et cavaliers pts 5
voilà donc pour ça il va falloir y ont
fait d absolument d'autres coups de
cases noires voilà mais le foot cases
noires vous rendrez compte qu'il a
beaucoup de mal à sortir à cause du plan
b de en l'air voilà donc ça c'est un
petit problème alors que feront les
blancs pour s'en débarrasser eh bien on
joue à trois voilà donc ça c'est un
point clé à jouer ici un couple et si
vraiment surjoue pas la variante avec
10,3 il faut jouer à trois avec l'idée
avec l'idée de jouer b 4 et 4 pour se
débarrasser de la faiblesse en v2 déjà
faire pression sur ces cinq forcer ce
pion à prendre une décision on prévoit
là on va voir falloir apprendre décision
de lancer 5 et ensuite on met le fou en
b2 pour surprotéger la surprotection le
principe de nîmes sauvage à ne pas
confondre avec passivité la
surprotection s'est consolidée à tout
prix notre seul point faible pour
empêcher leurs adversaires d'avoir du
jeu notre adversaire n'a plus ce jeu il
est besoin de jouer des mauvais coups
voilà notre et sans protection c'est un
principe simple il faut bien
différencier de la passivité
si les noirs jouent le coup qui aménage
6 on peut continuer avec b4 des quatre
voilà et la nascar faut pas une décision
en général par des qataris et ou de
l'autre c'est pareil elle est brisée
puis tout simplement on va pouvoir jouer
le fou en v2 voilà le fond en b2
tranquillement d'autrefois eu deux
petits rock cavaliers des deux cavaliers
b3 cac -3 et on va venir sur la belle
case c5 et après une fois qu'on est bien
parce qu'il est tout ça deux pièces
peuvent repartir de plus belle sur un
jeu tour c'est en elle même que l'on
sait on a un jeu classique sur la
frénésie 6 1
donc alors alors peut-être sur aa3 on
peut mentionner quand même une autre
option qui est su allier jouer au lieu
de cavaliers achi c'est les coûts c4 du
coup ces quatre séries qui essayent de
profiter de l'affaiblissement b3 et qui
empêche b4 myers a enfermé encore un peu
plus le fou c'est 8
alors à nous tenir
sur b4 simplement le rappeler si la
présentation et la prise en passant si
on peut prendre le pouls magath en
passant ici le pion à bouger de deux
cases on peut encore faire comme s'il
n'avait bougé que d'une seule case seul
cas aux échecs on prend une pièce
ailleurs que sur sa case voilà que ce
serait à égalité peu étrange mais donne
à tout charme
exactement donc ici alors là maintenant
que les noirs décidé de fermer le centre
eh bien on va attaquer à l'aise avec f4
f5 cavalli bien des deux l'a poussé
d'abord ans développe et se développe on
va voir la suite
donc ici par exemple ou 17 décès voilà
donc on n'est pas très important on va
regarder
l'idée j'ai trois voilages et 3 la
veille à 5 h 4 voilà l'idée c'est de
mettre le fou en as3 on va mettre le
fond h3 parce qu'on a visé cette
quinzaine ensuite on retire à cavalier
on jouera f4 f5 cavaliers f4 et f5
éventuellement g46 il faut mais là quand
le centre est fermé dans les ouvertures
on peut se permettre ce genre de
fantaisie à savoir les coûts de pions
sur les ailes puisque le le centre ne va
pas souvent tout de suite notamment jean
baptiste parce qu'ici faut pas oublier
que le point crucial de cette variante
voilà la colonne le point vertébrale de
cette de cette position c'est ces deux
chaînes de pions qui se regardent et qui
du coup bloquent le centre et dont elles
permettent de jouer à l'ehealth henry
sans trop s'en prendre aux riches
voilà c'est ça dont on peut se le
permettre voilà il faut simplement avoir
un oeil sur d'éventuelles sacrifice de
pièces ont ça en train que ça peut
arriver a toujours il faut on peut
regarder le puissant rebond des cats
on attendra n'aura pas donc
on revient sur wii on revient sur la
variante avec fu 17 élèves trois fous 17
alors cavalière 3 alors d'avoir damé
lorient sur nam b6 les deux bars donc
alors on peut jouer donc derrière à 3 on
le voir on peut jouer les 3 et là on va
voir une autre possibilité un fou dans
cette caisse ou décédées suite également
très joué et alors là l'idée c'est
toujours le même coup mais pas dans les
moments un or oui c'est les coups se
ressemblent toutes façons soit un ordre
ou un autre les coûts se ressemblent
anormalité dans cette partie qu'on a
choisi qui on a pas dit encore mme on a
choisi un bon spécialiste de la vente d'
avance pour montrer cette vivre cette
variante c'est alexei shirov du che en
voilà qui a joué très longtemps cette
variante de manière égale avec kabylie
ces trois d'ailleurs en mai il aime bien
la varende avance on peut également
citer gritche ou par exemple comme un
grand spécialiste de la vente d' avance
et surtout 17 alors il a une idée qui
n'est pas une idée qui lui appartient
mais notre ami shirov est un étang est
un fin connaisseur des prix des grands
principes de name is a [ __ ] et donc ils
avaient de surprotection du pionnier 4
il va jouer un plan avec plus tard
cavaliers à trois cahiers ces deux donc
on va pouvoir voir vouloir jouer des
plans comme ça voilà alors qu'est ce qui
change pour vous 17 pour les noirs c'est
qu'ils vont vouloir peut-être envie d
envisager de jouer tour s'évitera
lamente un jeu rapide sur la colonne
c'est voilà en effet elle n'aura pu te
reconnais c'est qu'il ne possibilité
fouet deux cas la legio 7
alors comprenez ce coup un cavalier ou 7
c'est pour aller dans les cinq
alors pour aller en effet encore si les
noirs jouent maintenant par contre
cavaliers h6 au oui je sais c'est une
autre possibilité mais en fait on en
fait un petit peu au même assez pour
aller en c'est pour aller enlève
ceinture c'est pour aller en scène de
façon mais ça ne s'est pas tout à fait
la même chose qu'on ne sait pas tout à
fait pareil comme comment on peut
envisager de faire fondre en cavalier
dans ce cas là c'est possible c'est faux
c'est une possibilité
voilà mais il faut savoir que c'est
s'est jamais clair c'est jamais clair on
dirait que c'est pas beau pour les noirs
mais en fait il faut savoir dans ce
genre de variantes fou prend à
shakespeare broyage schiste les noirs on
met le feu aux anges et 725 et au style
plus on est à côté d'avoir réussi se
venge de petit rock et f6 hélas la
disparition du fou de cases noires peut
être problématique pour les blancs donc
malgré
la mauvaise apparences du coke alias si
c'est un coût qui est jouable aussi je
vous prends aussi c'est un pari
audacieux mais intéressant parce que le
roi désolant sécurité pour vivre donc à
noter alors qu'à mes yeux cette voie là
alors s'allier à 3 1 qu'à lille je sais
qu'on peut juste dire stéphane que sur
une prise dans ses 5
oui parce que les pionniers oui alors
bien sûr bien sûr si les blancs prennent
ans et 5 serait sans une grosse faute
bah disons que ce serait parce que le
pion c5 est faible options c'est aussi
le cesne cavale et d'ici là le pion j'ai
eu 5 étant va tomber de toute façon même
si on le protège est-ce qu'il va pas
être facile mais on ne sait même pas
possible il faut pas protéger puis on
saigne tout simplement je ne peux pas
nous voulons mais d'ailleurs pas de room
c'est vraiment pas un bon coup laissé
les blancs ont sorti un plan du centre
c'est rarement bon coup dans le dos dans
des cas exceptionnels
alors voilà c'est ça l'idée qui est
capable d'envoyer 30 joli cahier à 3
parce que on peut revenir après c'est
prendre des claques s'éprend du cat on y
va on va voir en éclats tout de suite
l'idée c'est prendre les 4 et 4e 5calais
ces deux à l'atterrissage à un très bel
surprotection là je surprotège de macase
des cas donc qui courait la base de
machin lampions très important c'est
quoi en fait la surprotection s'est
laissé passer l'orage
en fait on a un point faible alors
d'accord dans les premiers coups on va
peut-être souffrir un petit peu pour
protéger ce point faible mais en juin
des coûts qui sont pas moches on est sûr
bien sûr les pièges qu'on développe et
tout ça et on s'intéresse à notre
faiblesse
et une fois que tout est bien
possibilités eh bien on va chasser une à
une des pièces qui nous ont embêtés au
début de la partie avec un effet
désastreux pour le camp qui a va subir
cette surprotection voilà donc il essaie
de leur l'avantagé assure protection
informatique peut-être ajouter un peu
c'est que chacune des pièces qui
surprotègent à la liberté de partir je
partirai oui voilà alors mais il y en a
qu'une qui peut partir à la fois mais
n'importe laquelle peut le faire voilà
parce que la surprotection c'est pas la
protection salle d'audience et a fait en
plus lassés de la protection
ça libère les autres pièces de la deûle
armes se rendent et de rester là donc
c'est une 120cc pas de catastrophe mine
de rien ça a l'air de on a l'air de
s'enfermer sur la protection d'un point
mais non parce qu'on libère les pièces
et surtout ont pris notre adversaire de
jeu et voilà donc comme l'exprimé in the
beach ou d'un moment notre adversaire de
la perspective et finit par n'avoir que
des mauvais coups se disent positionner
sur l'ensemble de ces exemples au milieu
d'une dame v6 pour les noix ou en maison
de boîte à questions des quatre ils vont
avoir du mal de rajouter une autre pièce
à la taxe on voit pas comment le fou il
suit pourrait rajouter de la pression a
ravagé 4 et la maintenance g4 seller
voilà la surprotection de permet de
déloger
voilà cheer up se réveille un lecavalier
le cavaliere 5 et 4 5 où il peut
paraître agressif c'est un coup en fait
seulement positionner c'est bien
maintenant on choisit de travailler fort
et même le petit rock qui a fait un
tyran qui a fait réfléchir officie ne
nous inquiète pas parce que les pièces
ne sont pas placés soit sur l'aileron
oui puis le jeu n'a pas de problème
exactement les pièces sonores sont
plutôt à une dame est et le centre est
bloqué le centre est fermé et même le
coup h5 joué ici par relevé l'icg et son
adversaire cette partie bien sûr et bien
ne nous inquiète pas puisqu'on grosses
olives tout simplement le coût sera
alors très important jean baptiste ce
coup là jamais se tromper il faut pas
jouer des coups comme j5 évidemment un
nom ils seront hors heures visant le
cavaliere bien voilà le cavaly
reviendrait à f/5 l'idée de se coucher 4
c'est bien le contrôle et cinq sur h5
voilà ni gphone incarner ni j'ai pas le
rush est exactement donc il faut
absolument garder le contrôle quand
luigi cats pour priver querellés kasab
seul devant la petite racontant la hache
proche des 4 je prends le cas de mes
sept tours ici évidemment elle est
menaçante un tout petit peu quand même
sur le roi blanc mais ya pas de pièce à
la taxe est quasiment impossible centre
est bloquée comment la dame pourrait
venir attaquer ici est même allé pas le
cas échéant pourrait jouer simplement
roger de éventuellement tourache un
échange et sept tours ce ministère y'a
pas grand danger mais n'y a pas danger
mais faut quand tension et de l'ordre ne
le prenez pas pour argent comptant
regarder avant de le faire comme un seul
homme et dans ce cas de figure où il est
écrit ci a que la tour qui la taxent
c'est pas du tout un problème exactement
m6 de l'acca de la part de la part de
nora une autre possibilité pour les
noirs ici donc ça aussi c'est normal il
faut réagir au centre
est-ce que les blanches de g4 il faut
quand même essayer de comprendre comment
les morts peuvent exploiter
et oui parce que là maintenant les
blancs si on laisse ce faire ils vont
ils ont joué très facile maintenant
après il suffit de finir le
développement et puis de jouer à trois
des quatre éventuellement être quatre
cinq fois une chose comme 3 et 4 et
ensuite on va sortir ce cavalier on va
chasser peut-être le cas et c'est 6
voilà on prendre de l'espace paddock
tout ramener ce mario à prendre de
l'espace et on va acculer les noirs pour
yann gaillard en voyage avec les noix
voilà sachant que les noirs ne sont pas
reliés comme un local si c'est quand
même un petit coup risqué exactement
alors une possibilité pour les noirs se
jouer le complexe m
voilà pour essayer d'attaquer le pion le
plancher 4 voilà on attaque le
protection la protection des câbles à
une idée si les blancs prennent évident
je prends de cavale et la très probable
et la strophe puisque là on peut plus
déloger ce cavalier qui devient énorme
donc il faut surtout pas donc il a un
très fort ce coup puisque si les noms et
les blancs eux mêmes prennent réussisse
après j'ai pris 6 6 à la belle colonne
j'ai mes dents qui s'ouvre alors là
c'est un désastre aussi parce que le
grand roque va suivre pour les noirs
avec une grosse attaque
qu'est-ce qui reste qu'une solution
alors là on applique un petit peu ce que
tu as vu tout à l'heure c'est à dire la
surprotection ce qui est bien c'est
qu'on peut quand même enlevé une pièce
de l'entente s'aggrave pas pour qu'on
joue cavalier g5 cavani s'en aille parce
qu'il atteindra kg 5 est dramatiquement
affaibli et le grand roque est
impossible à cause de la fourchette
fourchette arrive c'est taylor si les
noirs prennent en g4 habilité oui mais
attention je vais venir ici mais non là
ça commence à devenir un peu embêtant
pour le plan réussisse après vous prend
vous prend et maintenant pression sur la
faiblesse c'est l'énorme et non une
faiblesse d'autant plus que f4 f5 peut
venir éventuellement et ça peut aller
très vite
voilà l'idée est alors trois caméras
braquées bon autre option pour les noirs
ici si je voulais courir 6 voilà bien
dans ce cas là on comprend pas toujours
en et fils évidemment ces serrures
mandat
on enverrait la colonne géant force le
contrôle du centre pour les noirs et
puis on nous la colonne j'ai donc voilà
c'est rarement dont les blancs interdit
donc fou détroit voilà voilà ça c'est un
coup tranquille il faut des 3 way jean
baptiste qui vise les cases blanches
oui alors c'est aussi pour laisser la
casa la donne et s'allège la case ici
pour la dame d'eau qui va ou de viser
sur la colonne et la droite collègues
fort intéressante pour les poulains de
gamme ceux se trouvant à eux deux bien
sûr donc là les noirs eux mêmes la ne
prennent pas en règle si si ils prennent
s'ils prenaient le saint tout simplement
on poursuivrait par cavalli est
maintenant de 5 godasses des cavaliers
prend 17 qui supprime la protection de
la faiblesse par exemple le coût calais
c'était possible dans la drogue même
laissé lecavalier en le 5 est une bonne
option bien sûr car il prend le 5 des
produits sains les prend 1,5 des
promesses 5 et la nok a blessé six cas
la saisissante sur les pièces et là on
the damned sommes heureux et on protège
et protège voilà qu'une position
incertaine mais quand même très agréable
à jouer
on a du fou et 3 qui arrive
il faut 1 3 on n'a pas peur d'eux dans
le premier domaine on peut le faire
éventuellement si vous voulez quoi une
fois que les noirs ont fait grand cas on
aura des pelles grelotte sur la langue
rock que la loi n'a encore un jeu qui
est assez plaisant même rangée de f4
peut être envisageable
attention cases blanches quand même le
français 6 peut être désagréable tu peux
être migrés le pion fg saccades
bon il ya pas mal n'est pas le possible
est intéressant possibilités
intéressantes fou des trois grands rock
grand roque
voilà un an maintenant qu'on est à
l'adresse ça peut comme d'habitude à
l'adresse du roi maintenant le roi et là
ça y est on sait où il est donc on peut
y aller des quatre on a peur de
sacrifier en sacrifiant le tube et 4
puisqu'il peut être pris par le cavalier
c6 mais ça serait une erreur tout
simplement à cause du simple tourbe et
de toute façon fait tomber et le
cavalier cloué sur la dame et si on le
protège avec la scène tout simplement à
3 est terminée ça vient d'une pièce et
b4 bien déjà menace quoi menace de jouer
à 5 à 4 à 5 0 et laval et voilà ça va
aller très très vite alors navet noir
ont une façon de réagir peut être qui
est intéressante a voulu vous faire
partie des cavaliers prend des cadenas
maintenant on peut prendre en d4
alors pourquoi parce qu'une fois qu'il
ya une reprise en d4 et c'est ce qui
s'est passé on va peut-être regarder car
il s'éprend des 4 et bien f prend le 5.5
donc là on va récupérer la pièce puisque
le cavalier des cats attaquer on pourra
jouer ensuite quatre alors qui fait
alors ça a l'air bon pour les blancs les
noirs sein à la première vue ça a l'air
bon mais si on regarde de plus près
regarde dameuse coup je vais pas d'offre
voilà maintenant ça veut dire prendre si
tu veux dès que tu prends je souffre f4
hongrois et croise alors voilà six pions
prend des quatre dans ce cas là le
simple et très beau fou et 4 et regardez
regardez la puissance de secours puisque
le roi ici val ok on voit le plan b 4 et
le foin f k qui collabore à 706
pourvoyeur bloguer menace tour c'est un
échec car la partie tout va bien donc
bon bien senti un peu compliquée en est
sûre on a simplement voulu vous montrer
un exemple ce qui est le plus
intéressant dans cette partie stéphane
c'est le principe initial de
surprotection voilà voilà
c'est cette manoeuvre qu'on a vu le fou
décède le fou ces huit des noirs est
enfermé notre principal point faible
c'est le pion de 10,4 dans un premier
temps tâcher de le défendre de
surprotéger est naturellement vos pièces
se retrouveront bien placé après est-ce
que vous pouvez chasser les pièces
noires qui dans un premier temps montré
une belle activité c'est vrai mais ça
n'a pas suffi
pour prendre l'avantagé et on peut les
refouler après facilement le thématiques
aussi g4 à noter toujours c'est très
souvent dans la française aux droits
d'accès notamment g4 à bien doser 1 à
bien doser fait le petit rock
attention
y pas que c'est bon en toute situation
c'est quand même un coût qui est
thématique et puis plein de plein de
belles idées qu'on a vu on n'a plus le
gambit milner barry par exemple avec le
sacrifice de planck est une autre option
pour le genre d'attaqué éventuellement
voilà plein de petites variantes
thématiques dans cette phrase davance
j'espère que vous aurez bien aux rémois
3 3 3 grandes notions effectivement ce
gambie fou détroit sursaut d'un v6 ou a3
de surprotection à troyes b 4 et
cavaliers à trois cas au lycée de carrie
ya trois qualifiés d' outils archi
classique des classiques on va choisir
en fait un euro son style souvent son
style c'est dans ses variantes là donc
c'est une variante riche la française
d'avant ce qui est quand même donc à
dans un fonds positionner fort à cause
de ces structures de vraiment un briquet
au sens donc et quand même pas facile à
un jeu direct 8 et au début elle vient
de dire m mais avec beaucoup de
ressources tactique aussi des ressources
tahitien qui par ailleurs faisait
n'importe quel moment
on espère qu'avec les noirs aussi vous
aurez pu choisir l'orientation que vous
souhaitez parce qu'il ya pas mal de
choses intéressantes vous avez vu oui
nous on donne des idées avec aïda blanc
mats ek les noirceurs des idées pour
tous ept cette française bien sûr et
puis on essaiera peut-être dans les
autres leçons de présenter d'autres
variantes parce que c'est une défense
qui est très riche
voilà tout à fait m'écouter on vous
remercie pour d'avoir suivi cette cette
leçon sur la française d'avant ce voile
alors voir en vrai je me dis